-It is so nice to see you.
Welcome to the show.
Thank you.
I want to talk
about "Creed III."
-Okay.
-You're like the queen
of movie franchises, by the way.
-No, I don't know
if that's true.
-Well, you're in two mass--
I mean, you're also in "Thor."
-That's --
Yeah, that is true.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-So, I mean --
-[ Laughs ]
Is that exciting?
I mean,
do you think about that?
-I am the king
of movie franchises.
-Yes, you are the king
of movie franchises, sure.
-Valkyrie's the king.
No, it's a trip.
I never imagined, you know.
But being in a movie
where there's lots of
like CGI and greenscreen,
that was a bucket list thing
for me.
-Yeah. Is it fun?
-It's so fun.
I think just, you know,
when you watch movies
and you realize that,
when someone's doing this,
an action scene
and they're supposed to be
on a spaceship,
that, really,
they're in a green room
and there's probably a guy
eating a sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, it's like
it seemed like a really
challenging thing,
as an actor, so.
No, they're
always eating sandwiches.
[ Laughter ]
There's always guys
eating sandwiches.
-Oh, is that right?
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah.
-But it's a joy.
And also to do films
that kids love.
I feel like there are
so many parents
across, you know, America,
certainly,
that have selfies of me
for their children
and that's really sweet.
-Yeah.
Yeah, you were saying you went
to the premiere
of the last "Thor"
and you said you were just
hanging out with everyone's kids
because they
were just so excited.
-Oh, yeah. Everyone was talking
to other like cool actors
that had come
and I was just with like the kid
of the line producer all night.
[ Laughter ]
And he's like,
"So, when you were doing this,
what was really happening?"
I'm like, "No, that's what
really was happening."
[ Laughter ]
Tessa Thompson,
I'm happy you're here.
I read a lot about you, getting
ready for this interview,
and I read something,
I said to myself,
"This can't be true,"
but can you tell me
if this is true or not?
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-I read that you've never
eaten eggs.
-That is a true thing.
I've never had an egg.
Hard-boiled, scrambled,
omeletted.
[ Laughter ]
Deviled.
-Is omeletted a --
-Is it?
-You invented -- Wait.
How have you gone through life
never having an egg?
-Okay, well,
I think it started
because I had some
misinformation about eggs.
My parents never told me
that like
the eggs that you eat
would never become a chicken
and so, like morally,
I was like, I, you know,
they should be chickens someday,
so I didn't eat eggs then.
And then also, just like
once I understood that,
I just didn't trust them,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
Because they shape-shift.
Like one second, they're this.
One second, they're that.
-They're a frittata.
-Yes!
-Then they're an omelet.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
It's suspect, as a kid,
if you think about it.
You know what I mean?
-You go, "What is an egg?"
-What is an egg? And then I --
-"Is it a solid?
Is it a liquid?"
-I was so serious about it,
I didn't even eat eggplant
for the longest time
[ Laughter ]
because I thought
-No relation!
-it was connected.
I was so committed.
But then I got to a certain age
where it was kind of my shtick,
you know what I mean?
Like here I'm talking about it
on late night television.
It's like a remarkable thing,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
-So, you're kind of like --
-You got to hold on to the ways
in which you can be exceptional
[ Laughter ]
and for me, it's not --
-This is not it for you.
-For me, not --
-It's a big party trick.
-I know, but --
-Seriously, I have been places
-You're in two giant
movie fra--
-and people are like,
"Yo, get over here.
She's never had an egg!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's not!
What parties have you been to
where someone's like,
"Get over here.
She's never had an egg"?
-I have --
-That's not true.
-They're really fun parties,
let me tell you.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to be invited
to those parties.
Tessa, I don't want
to put you on the spot
or anything like that,
but would you ever --
would you ever try an egg,
if I --
-Okay. See this?
Okay.
Michael B. Jordan tried to get
me to eat an egg last week
[ Laughter ]
because we have a thing.
We have a thing where --
First of all, Jonathan Majors
ate eight hardboiled eggs
for breakfast
when we were making that movie.
-Yeah, because he's jacked.
-Yeah.
And also, they could afford it
because I wasn't eating
any eggs.
[ Laughter ]
And then --
-You passed on them.
-Michael B got me to eat
my first bite of steak.
I had never had a steak.
And then when we made
[ Audience gasping ]
the first one --
I know, I'm losing.
[ Laughter ]
What do you -- What do you...
-Eat?
-Is that another party trick?
-Yeah.
-"You got to get over here.
She's never had steak."
[ Laughter ]
It's like, wow,
this party's getting old
real quick.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-But now I don't have
those anymore,
so, last week,
I declined the egg.
-[ Gasps ]
-But then I thought to myself,
like, I am the kind of person,
like I believe in like
I'll try anything once.
So, it is sort of weird
that I've never tried an egg.
-And you would
do it tonight for us?
[ Ohhs ]
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, no!
-Tess.
I don't --
Tessa, I don't want you
to smell the egg or anything.
-I know.
-I have ketchup as well.
Yeah, but the eggs
are a different thing.
I don't want you to like --
I don't want to steer you wrong.
Do you have a --
-How do you eat your eggs?
[ Laughter ]
No one's ever came
on "The Tonight Show"
and asked me a question.
[ Laughter ]
It feels special to me.
That was like the only party
trick I had going for me, but --
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I'm ready to try
new things tonight.
I like fried eggs. I like --
Sunny side up is my jam.
-Oh, okay, okay.
-Yeah.
Scrambled, too.
-Fried eggs look really nice.
-They're cool-looking, right?
-Like in sandwiches and on top
of rice and things.
-Cartoons.
-Cartoons, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, they look nice,
but scrambled is the way
we prepared them tonight.
-[ Inhales sharply ]
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
But they're not -- they're not
runny or anything, right?
[ The Roots play
whimsical tune ]
-Hold on.
No.
They're not runny.
Do you want to see them?
-Yeah!
-Okay, good.
[ Laughter ]
I want to open them over here.
I just don't want you to get
a waft and get and then --
[ Laughter ]
and then bail.
-But see --
how do you eat eggs,
if that's how you have to --
I normally don't have them
under a silver container.
It was like this is very fancy,
fancy, scrambled.
This is right from the
Waffle House from Florida.
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
[ Oohs and laughter ]
Now, these are scrambled eggs.
They actually look really good.
Now, do you want --
Do you want ketchup?
Do you want hot sauce?
-Hot sauce.
-Alright, throw it on there.
Tessa Thompson trying eggs
for the first time ever.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Alright. Take your time.
Oh, yeah, so what do you think
of the consistency?
-Ooh, there's moisture!
[ Laughter ]
A little spongy.
-What is the moisture from?
It's from the egg.
-It's like egg water?
[ Laughter ]
-The egg --
-Ooh!
Okay. Alright.
-Is that what you do
when you get nervous?
-Yeah.
-Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You got it, bud.
You got this!
[ Whistling ]
Come on! You got this, buddy.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Drink water.
Drink water. Drink water.
Here's water.
No, no? Okay, she's okay?
Hold on.
Do you have a decision
or do you have anything?
-[ Clears throat ]
-No? Nothing.
-Okay.
-Wow. That's it, you did it?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That's it.
We don't have to bring it up.
-Ahh!
-We don't have to talk
about anything. Wow!
-But now it's like documented
that I have eaten an egg.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. And how did it feel?
-Now I got to let it go.
Actually, they're not bad.
-There you go!
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Eggs are delicious.
[ Ring ]
They're not bad.
-They're not bad.
-Wow!
We started a whole thing.
Now, every time you come
on the show,
you have to try a food
that you've never had before.
[ Laughter ]
Can we talk about the movie,
please?
-Yeah.
-Congratulations
on this already.
It's getting great reviews.
-Thanks so much.
-"Creed III."
Can we set up what's going on?
It's you, Michael B. Jordan.
Michael B directed.
-Michael B directing, yeah.
-I know. I thought earlier,
I thought you said
Michael B'Jordan
and I was like
[ Laughter ]
"Do you call him Michael
B'Jordan, like an apostrophe?"
It's a period, yeah. It's not
-It's a period.
[ Irish accents ]
-Michael B'Jordan. No, it's
-Oh, Michael B'Jordan.
-Michael B. Jordan.
-Yes, Michael B. Jordan.
-What's He like to direct?
-Oh, he's great.
He's so great.
-And, being from Ireland,
how long have you
[ Laughter ]
worked with him?
You pretended you're American
in the movie.
-I know, no, I just
-I know you're in Philadelphia.
-Cobbled over.
-I know.
-[ Own accent ]
Is is it interesting
getting direction from a person
who's also acting
in the movie as well?
-[ Own accent ] Yeah.
-How does he yell cut?
-So, that's what I wondered
for about a month and a half.
And then I discovered --
And then I discovered
that he would do this really
subtle like little cut sign.
-Oh, wait.
Oh, so out of the frame?
-No, no, no,
just like he would just like
hide his hand and be like doop!
[ Laughter ]
-Really?!
-Yeah.
-Is it left
in the movie anywhere?
-Yeah, that's a good question.
I don't know.
-He's like, I'll be
right back, honey.
[ Laughter ]
Take care."
-Doop!
-And you go, "Whoa!
That's what Adonis does.
That's one of his moves."
-He did it in the middle
of a very emotional scene
and I was like, "Wow,"
but otherwise,
he really was seamless.
I didn't feel like
I lost my acting partner.
-I thought he crushed it.
I thought he did a great job.
-Yeah. He really did.
The only difference is,
you know,
he has a say, of course,
as the director,
in anything that happens
in the film
and he's very specific
about clothing,
which I didn't know.
-Oh!
-Yes. So, we never disagreed
-Like wardrobe?
-about anything,
except, sometimes
what shoes I would wear.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?!
-Yeah. He's really like
down to the --
He doesn't --
-He's like, "Your character
would not wear this."
-He just has ideas
about ladies' fashion.
[ Laughter ]
-And how was he?
Was he correct?
-Yeah...
Okay, so,
[ Laughter ]
there was a party.
There was a party scene
where I really wanted
to wear something specific.
I wanted to wear all black
because I'm like secretly goth
[ Laughter ]
and I never got to be
in high school, so now I am.
And he was like, "No, no, no.
I think you -- No.
You're not going to wear that."
And I was like, "Huh?"
But he was right in the end.
-Yeah, he was?
-Yeah, he was.
I can admit when I'm wrong.
-Your wardrobe didn't take me
out of the movie.
-Yeah.
-You looked gorgeous.
-Thanks very much.
-Stunning. It was perfect.
Perfect for your character.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
Can we set up what's going on
with "Creed III"?
-Yes.
So, in "Creed III,"
you find Adonis,
who's played by
[ Irish accents ]
Michael B'Jordan...
-Ah! He's one of my favorites.
[ Own accent ]
...and myself.
I play a singer
who now has stopped performing,
but owns her own record label
and is producing artists.
-[ Own accent ] Producer.
-And Mike is stepped away
from the boxing ring
and he's, essentially, you know,
looking after boxers
and has his own gym
and they're successful
and they're rich and they're
famous and they're happy.
-And then ding dong!
-And then in comes someone
from Adonis' past,
who stands to sort of,
potentially, destroy everything.
And he has to -- because it's
a boxing movie --
get back in the ring.
-That's right
[ Cheering and applause ]
and everyone goes nuts
when they're watching it.
If you want to --
It's so exciting.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Tessa Thompson
in "Creed III."
Take a look at this.
-So, Miss Producer,
when's your next show?
-I don't really perform
like that these days.
Yeah, I took a break
because I was --
I was having some issues
with my hearing onstage
and now I'm trying to be careful
and preserve what I got left,
so...
I'm producing.
Yeah.
Not anytime soon. [ Laughs ]
-Still hard to give
that part up, though.
Right?
-Yeah. It's not the only thing
I love, but it takes work.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
Tessa Thompson, everybody.
"Creed III" is
in theaters and IMAX now.
Andy Cohen joins us
after the break. Stick around.